hi everybody today we're talking about
character deaths you know death is um
ever present
i'm just gonna
drink some
sangria
i don't know why we have this a lot of
you commented and and gave a lot of
wonderful interesting comments that i
have yet to read
sweet that's what we're doing right now
we got 181 comments on youtube but i'm
not gonna talk about all of them because
that would be a three hour video but
let's get into this it hurts more when a
character is a traitor slash betrays
someone than if they die yeah this is
correct but when they die there's sort
of a closure there a little bit at least
in fiction not in real life death in
real life there's not really
rarely closure
wow that got really dark hot take joshua
is actually the main character all along
and the job of donald green and brian
sanders is to help jake realize that
this is why he makes a miraculous escape
at the climax of the 18th novel and
takes his revenge on his true villain
jake by taking the kids and deborah away
all right donald green would never do
that to me okay when a character dies
off screen slash off page uh it's
expected that they don't really die
would it be interesting to try it and go
against that norm once in a while that
would be
that that would actually be pretty
interesting just like a really obvious
setup for a character not actually dying
they're just like oh yeah this person
died off screen totally and then they
just do and the whole time you watch the
movie you're just like oh they're going
to come back at a certain point then the
movie ends and you're just like oh
oh i guess they just they just died when
a character dies there needs to be time
for other characters to grieve sometimes
the reactions are more impactful and
emotional than the actual death
but if the author just brings them back
don't have hundreds of pages spent
grieving that's very true
i can't help thinking but but to think
of star wars the rise of skywalker i
think those of you who have seen it will
know what i mean and to me what makes a
character dying in a story is so
impactful it's not that they are gone i
mean obviously that has is made we're
losing that character you know from the
story whatever they could have done is
gone but it leaves a hole for all of the
dynamics and it creates a you know a
title shift
for how all the characters are going to
deal with this you know death the reason
why it has to be used sparingly and in
storytelling is because it's it's it's
huge it's monumental and it's going to
change
characters it should change characters
and some of them forever i really enjoy
when an author effectively kills a
character in a way that surprises and
crushes the reader sue me yeah
yeah yeah i'm a bit annoyed with how
hung up a lot of people seem to be on
the idea that for any story to be
considered uh to have stakes characters
have to die constantly and also that all
the bad guys automatically deserve to
die i feel like game of thrones broke a
lot of brains you know game of thrones
comes up uh so much i feel like when
talking about character deaths because
uh i don't think any show or
or series has surprised people and
brought new things um to character
deaths and mainly it's just about main
character deaths i think um we're used
to side characters dying in fact some
characters uh we expect them to die and
yeah all bad guys don't automatically
deserve to die i mean i guess deserve is
kind of a weird word i i just think that
it's expected for the bad guys to die
um when honestly there's like way worse
things like if you want to punish the
bad guy i think there's way worse things
than death for the
villain to go through i'm gonna use this
comment to kind of uh encompass the
whole resurrection theme here if a
character is dead let them stay dead
don't uh bring them back to life for
god's sake i feel like this should
almost always be the case if you do you
have to have like rules established
about character resurrections if you do
it once you you really can't do it again
it just cheapens it and you'll see some
shows uh you know that have just been
going on for too long where they just
have to start resorting to these kinds
of things it gets tiresome the
contradictories says make uh don't
foreshadow it all the time surprise me
make it sudden uh so that it hurts and
show me the character's dreams and plans
before so that i know what i'm losing
and this kind of opens up this idea of
foreshadowing to me like sometimes
foreshadowing you don't need it you know
i feel like we really praise
foreshadowing as like you know it's a
great device and especially when you're
rereading a series it can be really fun
but
things like a character's death it can
work a lot better when it just happens
joshua's death was stripped of meaning
when the author brought him back to life
after he fell off the grand canyon
i like when characters see or enter
alternate realities and get all messed
up that the people they know are dead
there yeah absolutely we were watching
um jumanji recently the original jumanji
and because i love that movie spoilers
for jumanji i'm sorry if you haven't
seen jumanji but when robin williams
come back comes back
you know to the 1990s and finds out that
his parents are dead it's like that's
such a sad scene and it's kind of like a
similar similar thing the resurrection
trope is actually fine especially in war
epics i think we should get more main
characters getting irreversibly hurt
then dead that is a lot more painful to
read well i see what you mean about the
irreversibly hurt and that can be
super effective also you know i think a
lot of writers don't use that as much as
death
maybe because it's harder to write about
also but yeah like an injury a major
injury can can totally change a story
but i still don't think the resurrection
trope is fine it shouldn't be a trope it
should be like super super rare i
honestly just enjoy my favorite
characters dying i can't help it it's
how i'm made
who made you most of the time killing a
character is the worst way to conclude
an arc and especially if the series goes
on it ends up removing a great dynamic
audience is loved i do generally think
that killing a character at the end of
their arc is pretty ugh lame because you
can get to the end of an arc and have a
new arc or you can get to the end of an
arc and then just be there you know i
think it gives this sense of resolution
to death that i don't think should be
there you know when death comes in a
story i think it should be messy and
leave a lot of open ends but a lot of
times you'll see a character die in a
show or a series or you read about a
character dying and they've gotten to
the end of their story so it seems like
okay that they're dying like darth vader
you know he gets to the end of end of
his character arc so it's like it's fine
you know he's he's he became good you
know so it's fine that he dies
i don't i don't love that you know can
work and
it works at star wars but
i think that's a pretty
cheap thing to do i don't like when a
character dies and then an alternate
version of them is brought in it takes
away the original's life and worth and
mutes the grieving process and the
thought that somebody can be replaced so
easily really galls me this reminds me
of a lot of cw shows um yeah there's
some weird implications there so i i
agree there personally i believe that a
series no matter how good it is is
ultimately a failure if all the
characters are still alive by the end
they must all die
and they said it was it was not a joke
if all the characters aren't dead by the
end have you really told the full story
i mean you got to follow them from
cradle to grave some characters wouldn't
be as loved or appreciated if they
didn't die
this is so true for some characters
dying is is really the saving grace of
their their character arc it can really
um make or break a character if they die
at the right time you know they just did
something heroic they're they're
terrible their whole lives but they do
something heroic and then they die and
it's like oh yeah they they ended on a
high note so that's good but if like
immediately if they stayed alive for
like 24 hours longer and they just
continued to be shitty then it'd be like
yeah i don't i don't know if he was
really good
my biggest pet peeve is when something
so fatally violent damaging occurs
followed by he or she was dead suddenly
a cannonball hit bob directly in the
face tearing his entire head asunder as
his decapitated likeness fell upon the
floor with a grotesque thud displaying
red across the once pristine hardwood
he was dead
like yeah no [ __ ] bob is dead if i cry
out to character death that means you're
the best author of all time yeah i don't
i don't cry at character deaths all that
wait
never mind i do sleep character dying
woke fate worse than death bespoke
character death by completely derailing
their characterization from what it was
if you really want to kill a character
in the hearts of a reader
just destroy their characterization and
just make them the worst character ever
because they will forget about that
character they will be dead in their
hearts even if they live on the page
resurrection erases the meaning of a
character's sacrifices and absolutely
wild take and i see it so often a
resurrection doesn't erase the pages
where a character dies it just
contextualizes the character's arc in a
new light like every event in every
story i see where this is coming from
because you you can't just discount all
resurrection if if the story
fundamentally changes while the
character is dead and then when they're
resurrected it changes again yeah that
that can be great what i don't like is a
kind of
false
change or a false sense of change that
is immediately corrected or all these
new problems occur because this
character is gone and then
um all of a sudden the character comes
comes back and it's all fixed uh no i
think it should be you know the stakes
are different now because of however
this character came back it's creating
new problems it's a lot more interesting
for a character to live than to die i
mean yeah because the character is going
on death is
i think every character should be killed
no survivors from the tiniest baby to
the old wise wizard have no mercy no
more characters they are all dead
this why doesn't this have more likes
this is uh i agree uh wholeheartedly i
don't have anything to say at the moment
just wanted to comment okay bye that's
okay i'm gonna keep your i'm gonna keep
your comment on screen and make
everybody stare at it for uh
50 seconds overly average ben says we
need more narrator deaths george rr
martin is the only one brave enough to
do it and leave a song of ice and fire
unfinished um there's this uh marty
robbins song that i love where the
singer of the song dies
at the end of the song and is singing
about how they're dying forget which one
it's called i think it's might be el
paso the first three stormlight books
don't have enough deaths relative to the
stakes and risk present a lot of the
deaths mentioned are the ones that
happened the past i
agree only one
had had a really significant impact on
me because the rest it felt like
these were characters that were
basically cannon fodder another one
brandon sanderson is scared to kill his
main characters i wouldn't say you
wouldn't say he's scared i just don't
think it it necessarily fits his type of
universe and and the tone that he goes
for in his in his world please don't
call authors cowardly or too attached
just because they haven't killed any
main characters a perfectly amazing
high-stakes story can be written without
murdering beloved characters gosh darn
it yeah i i totally agree you know you
don't have to kill your characters in
order to have uh good stakes in a story
there's so many other ways to do that i
feel like as evidenced in a lot of these
comments people love seeing
characters live and deal with the
consequences of the real world and a lot
of times death is kind of an easy way to
get
to solve a character arc um i've thought
about it sometimes in my writing where i
go
do i really need my character to die
here or do i just not really don't
really want to think about what's going
to happen next to for them or or is the
story
just becomes more complicated if they're
still around and i'm just doing it
because i don't want to deal with the
complications and i just want them to
have a nice clean resolution and i go oh
yeah i mean if i'm just using death for
a clean resolution then that's that's
not good enough reason for it um it's
got to really
serve the story in a bigger way death
does not equal redemption death is a
cheap way to avoid having a character
face the consequences of their actions
by having them make the noble sacrifice
exactly this is
exactly what i've been saying i want to
see more villains actually having to put
in the work to atone for the wrongs they
committed
i'm looking at you star wars and i love
star wars but i'm looking at you star
wars to improve
their similitude
that's a that's a word i want your book
to actually kill me the reader too
yeah
wouldn't that be real immersive man if
you weren't in the middle of reading it
i'd have some things to say lol but oh
well don't don't if any of these
characters in the wheel of time
die i
i don't i don't know what i'll do psa to
all the fantasy mentor figures to ditch
the kid they're training because y'all
gonna bite it yeah mentor them give them
the advice they need and never talk to
them again that's how it should be with
high school teacher that house should be
with anybody any for any teacher okay my
opinion man carrying things should not
survive his piece on character deaths
i
i resent that a dramatic sacrificial
death is not a redemption arc it's a
cheap cop-out and lazy riding yes i i
hate i hate that kind of sacrificial
death especially when it's a character
that they've done horrible things and
they just do one token thing
to be
remembered as great i just what about
their whole lifetime of doing horrible
[ __ ] bringing back dead characters to
life is fine and doesn't ruin stakes or
consequences i'm not even gonna finish
reading that comment because that's
wrong
everyone else has convinced me at this
point that it's wrong gorb
gorb says if every single character
doesn't die by the end of the book it
isn't grim dark enough and is probably
why a trash are you really a writer if
you don't kill every all of your
characters especially all at once so the
majority of the comments are
resurrection bad killing characters
suddenly is pointless but also we should
be killing characters suddenly more
often let's see what twitter has to say
man carrying depression oh cam wolf this
is this is good um not enough character
deaths involve the characters freaking
out that they're dying it's always
heroic and beautiful instead of dripping
snot crying and screaming every time i
think every time i watch a character
death these days i think about how
in real life when a like a person dies
usually they like release
you know you know i'm talking they
release themselves
so there's it's not a pleasant smell
seems like it'd be very uncommon for
someone to be very composed in a
situation like that there's no body the
person's not dead simple is that true
david says should kill off all the
characters in the first chapter everyone
knows real literature is just a
collection of nature descriptions and
vibes
that's actually i would read that
killing of parents or parent figures or
mentor is just uh too common now that it
loses uh the feel yeah it's it's really
just expected i feel like you you really
can't kill a mentor figure like you used
to you know you can't have that kind of
fun anymore resurrection trope done
wrong creator announcing joshua's death
when they very well knew he was alive
and well i didn't know he was ah come on
larry don't get me mad like that josh
neller says every character death scene
is impactful enough but the most
heartbreaking is when you threaten your
character that's even worse than death
the main character losing a dear loved
one the said uh main character losing
her uh memory or personality absolutely
there are things worse than death in
fiction and stuff horrible stuff that
can happen to your characters besides
death so why put them through death if
you're just going to resurrect them put
them through something worse
and then you don't have to do the
resurrection trope
you know problem solved if you're a
writer every series should end with the
main characters dying to prevent garbage
like rugrats all grown up
i love
i feel like there are so many examples
you could do of that
but you choose rugrats all grown up
i will always care more about a
character's death because they mattered
to me than because they matter to other
characters even when taking empathy into
account they need to be
feel earned at least to me i i agree on
this because a lot of times a writer or
they don't have time to really build up
a side character who dies so you'll hear
other characters talk about oh wow
they're this great person and they did
this for me and i saw them do the oh
they're a good person doesn't really
matter because it you you as a reader
have to feel some kind of connection to
them and usually you have to see their
actions on the page you can't just
really hear what other people are saying
about them you got to really see what
what they're doing and how they interact
in the world levi johnson the comic
relief must die it's the only way to
give the story stakes you know what
there are a lot of stories where i would
like the comic relief to have died i
feel like that's actually weirdly good
advice it that'd be so like instead of
killing the the wise old wizard mentor
kill the jester i'm looking at you wit
you know this has really opened my eyes
i feel like i have absorbed the opinions
of millions so if i ever write
another story again
i will either make sure all of the
characters are alive constantly and no
one dies or i will make sure all of the
characters die within the first 15 pages
this has been a lot thank you to
everyone who submitted i read all of
your comments and tackled my brain is
going to explode thank you so much for
watching have a good one everybody and
i'll see you all
parasocially
in the future bye bye
you